it's not that we hate people it's that
we hate shallow conversations yeah we
want something that's deep and
meaningful I forgot how I was going to
open up my speech serving others is
hardwired into US it makes you feel good
how do you find your purpose
hey hey it's happening
I was not expecting this
this hard well I wasn't either but here
we are yes
so let me ask you something so I I went
to the person that says I'm I'm infj too
which I think is how we first connected
or you're coming to us with an idea or I
comment down something new day and I
forget way back
um
so Thursday so today's Thursday Thursday
is my extrovert day even though I'm
super introverted Thursday is where I
just put on my extrovert hat and all day
long I'm doing interviews and podcasts
and hangouts and IG lives and I just
find it easier and I don't know enough
about infj but maybe this maybe this is
actually really helpful or maybe just
I'm super weird but
I like having I like knowing that just
one day a week
I get to do all of my interviews and
just cure the energy I actually gain
more energy over the day by being just
in that mode and I don't have to worry
about
writing writing my next book or or
making videos or anything else
um
is that do you find that that is uh like
one are you the same way and that you
like having different things with
different days uh and two is that is
that like an infj thing or is that just
I've been Carmichael is a weird deck
people to put ourselves out there and to
connect with other people so scheduling
it all in one day definitely helps a lot
and I need to be a lot more intentional
with that for sure
um I usually do a lot of it on Thursday
too because I have a couple of things in
the evening that I already have
scheduled so I'm like all right let's
just get it out of the way
um and plus it takes us so much time to
recharge that it's like why not do it
all at once and then have the whole rest
of the week to recover from it and I
also like knowing what's coming right so
I can be prepared for it I like that
routine too
so someone so so Maxie Mac Max CC wrote
that you're tired after your extrovert
day here's the thing so for me
the it's it's just kicking it off that's
the only thing that really
is the this is the hard part right so
um I just finished doing uh I have a
YouTube course I just finished going
live in that group and leading up to
that I'm I'm nervous and worried and
like who's gonna show up and what
questions are gonna ask but after the
end you're like that was amazing
right and so then I see Sarah go live
like I want to join in let's go live
together Sarah right like it it I
actually gain more energy so so by the
end of the day I'm probably gonna crash
but but come like two o'clock three
o'clock four o'clock whoever I'm talking
to uh I'm actually bringing the whole
energy of the I'm bringing Sarah's
energy all the way forward to the end of
the day but it's just getting started
that I find really difficult so that's
why I have one full day for it because
if I did bits of it every day then I'd
have the challenge of getting started
every day as opposed to just starting
once a week and then I have that whole
day to carry the energy forward yeah I
used to I have the same thing in fact I
used to tell people that I hate people
like I don't like being around people
because it's just so draining and it's
so much but once I started my podcast
and I started doing a lot of interviews
earlier this year with
um INFJs and other people who are
intuitive and it was the same thing when
I was getting ready to do an interview
I'm like oh what am I doing I don't want
to do this this is really hard and I
would have to force myself to actually
do it but during the conversation I
could feel my energy level rising and by
the end of the conversation I'm the same
with you I'm like yes that was so
awesome let's go do another one because
it was so cool it's it's the connection
that we're looking for and connecting on
things that we're passionate about and
talking to people who care about what
we're talking about just that deep those
deep conversations that we really want
it's not that we hate people it's that
we hate shallow conversations yeah we
want something that's deep and
meaningful yeah in my language it'd be
like serve right you built to serve you
want to know that the work you're doing
matters and is serving other people
um yeah a thousand percent like if you
woke up and felt like the work that you
did matters
I think that's such a great gift and
you're you're willing to you love you
love actually talking to people knowing
that you're helping them we want to help
others so we're afraid of others and
their judgments and you know opinions
and everything and so like that's the
constant battle
um yeah I'm with you I was on an
airplane uh late last year I was
speaking at an event in Puerto Rico and
I was on an airplane and I hate talking
to the guy next to an airplane right
like hate it I never do it I remember
everything about this guy that he woke
up at you know two in the morning to
catch a flight to get here and he he
likes his coffee decaf with one sugar
and one cream and all this stuff but
he's trying to make small talk and it's
like
I'm just trying to not be rude right
it's like yeah let me just let me do my
thing I hate talking about the weather
or the cushiony airplane or like
whatever
um but then I when I landed in Puerto
Rico uh I found out that he was at the
same event that I was speaking at
he was and then and then uh I saw him
the next day and then we started talking
about
his business and how I can help him then
it was an instant click because if you
know that that you can help them you can
serve them it shifts the whole
conversation because now there's a lot
of depth and meaning much more than just
hey so why are you going to Puerto Rico
and just kind of make small talk
yeah yeah so can I ask you I haven't
done a lot of Live Events but that's
like the next thing that I want to do in
fact I was scheduling some right before
we got quarantined which was terrible
timing but it's terrifying for me to
talk in front of people especially in
person and I'm hoping it's going to be a
significant amount of people right at
least you know a few to begin with I
used to have a job where I had to speak
in front of like 25 people but it was
kind of a rehearsed thing so I knew what
to say every single week yeah how do you
deal with that I'm assuming it's a lot
more draining than just being live on
video so how do you deal with that uh so
I don't know that I call it draining
it's definitely a lot more stressful
um and again maybe you're the eye and
you know you're you're the infj like
master so I'm I just can speak from my
experience but
uh last year I was in um Arizona
speaking out event and and Dean um
bratzioski and Brandon Bouchard put on
this event every year did a couple
thousand people it was you know Eric
Thomas and them and and me I was like
Eric Thomas and I were the only external
speakers kind of brought in to speak a
couple thousand people and
10 minutes before going on stage is a
super lonely time like if you're in a
backstage at a big event nobody talks to
the speaker before they're about to go
on because they don't want you know it's
just like leave them in their zone so
um
I I decided I was gonna go off with no
slides just because right so now I've
got to speak for an hour with no slides
so there's nothing even to save me it's
like oh right yeah I'm talking about
that thing right
and um I I forgot what I was gonna start
with
so I I was backstage kind of pacing
practicing just trying to remember what
I was going to do and I I forgot how I
was going to open up my speech
and I just had this now mental image in
my head of me going up and bombing and
failing and and disappointing everybody
and it's all my fault and holy cow this
sucks
um and I haven't had an anxiety attack
like that in a long time to that degree
I'm always worried about disappointing
people but not to where it's like
crippling and I forget and and it's
still service that saved me so I I
peeked out of the curtain and I looked
at the audience and I said I'm not I'm
here for them like I'm not here for me
this isn't even about me
I have information that can help those
people that that Brendan doesn't know
when Dean doesn't know and Eric Thomas
doesn't know I have I have knowledge
that can help those people stop being
selfish and get out there and and help
them and that calmed me down
maybe that maybe for others it just adds
more pressure but for me it's like oh
it's it's about serving people and I
have knowledge that can help that is the
thing that um
calm me down maybe remember what I was
going to do when I got on stage and then
and then went off and they ended up
giving me extra time on stage because it
was going so well which is great
um my favorite part of those things
though isn't even the stage work it's
the afterwards and this seems so weird
for an infj or maybe it's normal I don't
know
um I stay in the hallway for five or six
hours after the event like for me the
the joy isn't the speech it's the
one-on-ones afterwards
and I'll stay until the whole thing is
done I'll go home back to my hotel and
like die afterwards but I but I'm so in
the zone of helping people that I'll
forget to eat and forget to go to the
bathroom and not notice that I'm running
a fever because I'm I'm just in the zone
of helping people so much and I love the
speaking not for the speaking I love the
speaking as the setup to have people
come and ask me questions after so I can
help them
um
yeah so
that's what I do
I love helping people too and my biggest
fear as well is disappointing people
every time I think about my podcast or
the courses that I'm doing or you know
just being on Instagram it's like okay I
don't want to disappoint anybody and
every time I get terrified I go back to
that too
I'm here to help people and if I can
just help one person then that's all
that matters that's why I started my
Instagram account I thought if I could
just help one person and I never
expected there to be 50 000 people on my
Instagram account ever
we're just starting
it's happening I did because I just
started it like a year and a half ago so
yeah I'm I'm definitely a lot newer at
this than you are you've been doing this
for a long time
YouTube yes Instagram I'm a little bit
newer I went hardcore on Instagram maybe
two years ago
um YouTube 11 years I've had my my main
channel for so uh yeah it's pretty it's
pretty wildly crazy so here's the thing
though like if you're afraid of
disappointing people but you also want
to serve that's where most people get
held back
because serving involves other people
you can't serve without helping other
people but if you're afraid of
disappointing them then it's like having
your foot in on the gas and the break at
the same time like you know you're
capable of more you know you want to do
this thing but you're so afraid that you
don't go anywhere and you're just
spinning your wheels and so
um that reminded to myself at least is
like this is this is service this is to
help somebody my attention is good they
may not get it it may not work I may you
know you may start a podcast in its
talks and you may go live and make a
mistake but the intention is good as
long as the intention is positive the
intention to serve almost always that's
what ends up happening yeah so I want to
ask you a really big question because I
know you're probably gonna have a lot of
time
so many people ask me how do you find
your purpose so I'm going to ask you
that how do you find your purpose so
your purpose comes from your pain right
it's why I wrote this is why I wrote
built to serve right I mean because I've
got to ask that question so many times
and it's not that difficult
um it doesn't require years of
meditation or journaling or anything
else you just think about what is the
most painful moment for you as a human
and not like I broke my arm or something
not physical pain but emotional pain
when you felt the lows to the low you
felt worthless you felt like you have no
um no you know you're no point in life
um and you've grown from that you've
come out of that you're not
you're not where you want to be yet
because we're constantly growing but
you're way better than you used to be
whether that was six months ago or a
year ago five years ago
um there's lots of people who currently
are who you used to be
and your purpose is to go help them
and you represent help to them and
people default to thinking well I'm no
Tony Robbins or I'm no Brendan Bouchard
or whoever
uh excuse me they're gonna say I'm no
Sarah [ __ ] but
you can help right like you can you can
help the person who you used to be if
you think back to that person who used
to be five years ago you can help that
person in a way that Evan Carmichael or
Tony Robbins whoever can't
and so there's it's just understanding
there's lots of people who currently are
like that
um serving others is hardwired into US
it makes you feel good we all know it
they've done they've done functional
MRIs on people's brains and found that
that serving others hits the same part
of the brain as having food and having
sex which is also which are also
important as humans uh and and so it's
like it's hardwired into you to serve
and to help
but there's a difference between just
serving like buying the coffee the
person behind your line or holding the
door for somebody this is the moment
these acts of of service Good Deeds
versus a deep
fulfillment of helping other people go
through the thing that you went through
um so I love helping entrepreneurs
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
you know I quit on my first business
partner for a day I came back the next
day but I was like the lowest moment in
my life and so I want to make it easier
for other entrepreneurs not to struggle
and suffer as much as as I did I want to
make it easier for introverts to step up
like how does an introvert get on stage
and talk to 2000 people and have a
YouTube channel with 300 million views
and all that I don't know like I'm
figuring it out I mean I've done it and
I want to get even bigger
um and and just sharing that can be an
inspiration hopefully to other
introverts as well so that the pain that
you went through uh can either Define
you from a negative and you stay you
stay lost and trapped or can Define you
in a positive and say hey this is my
chance to serve and give back and help
everybody else is currently suffering
with this same thing
yes for sure that's that's exactly how I
found my purpose too that's why I
started my channel is because I was lost
as far as what my personality type was
and learning about it and I thought hey
if this information can help somebody
else then
yeah I need to put it out there I need
to do that and I was one of those people
who thought I didn't want to help other
people I read that about our personality
and I was like that's not really me I'm
more of a stay in the you know behind
the scenes type of person but then once
I started helping people
then I really found a passion for it and
I realized that's what I want to do and
I want to do more of it and more of it
more of it and
pushing myself past all of those fears
and insecurities is difficult but then
you go back to your why and yeah that's
worth it
I love it look what's happened
girl we just got the lies it's great I
love it anyway I saw you go live and
like this is awesome I wanna I wanna hop
in and just spread some love and thank
you for the conversation and I'm so
pumped to see you continue to grow where
you've come from such a quick amount of
time and I'm so pumped to see where you
take it in the next year and a half
yeah thank you and thank you so much for
all the inspiration I love your book I'm
telling everybody about it
um yeah thanks for joining us I really
appreciate it amazing thank you Sarah
bye bye
here we go
George is a part of my movement makers
program uh and as part of that we're
doing this IG live together too so
welcome aboard man how can I help what's
on your mind
first of all thank you very much for the
opportunity to meet you uh I actually
got to see you live I was at an Eddie
Panera event in Miami in 2019 I got to
see him in person I said you know what
someday I would love to work with Evan
and here we are thank you very much Evan
I love it man so
key things I would tell you first and
foremost I I'm not an IG Guy this is my
first Instagram that's why I had tools I
didn't even know
um I'm on YouTube I have 26 000
subscribers there big fan of all your
work throughout the years and uh quite
frankly um I'm in the blockchain space
and I generally what I do is blockchain
Bitcoin and crypto and uh I am I'm an
instructor I have over 160 000 students
worldwide in blockchain Bitcoin crypto
and I want to expand my impact by being
more active being able to create more
content like you being more open being
able to share
um among them my channels at 26 000
subscribers I would love to someday be
like you right so that's exactly what I
want to talk about how do I expand my
impact worldwide however let's go man uh
what are you selling let's start with
that are you selling training courses
coaching I have yes I have a series of
courses I have a series of
certifications also so a perfect example
would be like my courses include
blockchain Bitcoin fundamentals
cryptocurrency fundamentals metaverse
fundamentals nft fundamentals right and
then there's advanced level courses how
to create your own metaverse programmers
developers right so there's a whole
series of courses and then there's
certifications that I sell for people I
take multiple courses then they take a
certification these are internationally
credential and that's what we offer
right so the key goal is what I want is
to be able to share more of the content
like I do I publish on a weekly basis I
publish brand new videos and it's kind
of like what is bitcoin why is
blockchain the future you know what is
cryptocurrency things like that is how I
share but then the goal is to bring
people on board into this universe
called blockchain Institute of
Technology where we can help people
learn how to move this whole blockchain
movement forward that's really what I
believe in God I love I love the energy
I love the excitement I can tell you're
really into this stuff which is awesome
I even got my lava lamps which by the
way are part when people think about
cryptocurrency it's the cryptography and
crypto level lamps are a key component
of cryptography many people don't know
that okay I love it how much do you like
covering the news and what's going on
right now
um I I have not done as much as I could
mostly because there's so much
volatility and a lot of the content that
I've been focusing on is teaching
something as opposed to saying this is
what's happening in the world as opposed
to taking a position on things like for
example something huge that's happening
is ethereum is moving to proof of stake
in my world that's a massive thing I
haven't really done I haven't really
focused on that because I'm teaching
people how to create new
cryptocurrencies and right so it's it's
a choice I really don't talk a lot about
news
so you know is what you're doing now
it's like how do we have a bigger impact
the question is more like how much do
you enjoy covering that stuff
and having an opinion
well here's the thing
I the challenge with opinions that I've
always had is that in opelions sometimes
always someone's on the other side of
the opinion right so I personally I'm
not a big fan of what's going on with
proof of stake with ethereum and uh I'm
like I think it's something that really
hurts against the whole concept of
decentralization I never thought
ethereum could just switch like that
from one to the other one and screw an
entire industry of ethereum minors but
that's a personal opinion in the process
I'll piss off a lot of people if I
position that now the question is is
that necessarily a bad thing and that's
the key goal when you take a position
some people say you're on that side
you're not on this side therefore I
don't talk to you anymore right and
listen that's part of being an expert
you know like in you teaching and
training things it's it's you could have
just reported the news and sharing a
little bit without pissing people off
you know like the uh what news anchors
maybe used to be
like reporting on what's Happening and
even taking it as a as an example of
what people should learn and know so you
know El Salvador being on bitcoin pros
and cons how's it happening for them an
entire country moving there look this is
the future of where bitcoin's going even
if it's not working out so well for them
right now right you know this is still
the future if and there's still a lot of
good highlights going on it's just
people don't see those highlights
there's a lot of good stuff going on
well right so that could be that could
be you yeah that's a good point that's a
great point the people aren't seen
anymore you could be the guy here's Joe
George telling people so it doesn't have
to be pissing people off it's definitely
a brand
if I made videos talking about the top
10 stupidest things Kanye West has said
that video would blow but I don't want
to make that video it's not part of my
brain right now some people really still
hate on my video some people will will
you know even if it's all positive
you'll still always have somebody who
doesn't like the thing that you're doing
right but sure as long as the intention
going in isn't to piss people off you
could talk about ethereum moving to uh
to their you know youth to everything
and your your take on a pros and cons
without you can still acknowledge what
other people like hey this is actually
screwing people over who have who are
ethereum minors and now they don't have
a business anymore and it that really
sucks right and I still think it's like
good for where the industry is going
like you can recognize the other side
without saying that's cool you could
have it's just all the intent and how
you bring it up sure you still might
pissing people off but if you said
and all you losers who are youth mining
you guys come you knew this was coming
right like it's a completely different
approach yeah yeah that's cool so
there's so much education that needs to
happen in this space most people still
don't know what it is
you see ethereum walking down the street
nobody like most people 98 of people
have no idea what it is
so this definitely like you're on a
super hot topic right wait how I like to
think about content is it's great to
build an audience but it's better if I
if you understand the business model to
hey let's get an audience where you can
then convert to the thing that you're
trying to sell right so if you're if
you're trying to sell
teaching certification education then
it's great for you to make your videos
once a week
what I'd love to see you do is add in
some coaching videos
so you take something like literally
with human beings like what you're doing
right now with me this is it yeah
exactly this is it yeah I've never done
that
calls on that I just never have actually
turned it into part of the teaching
curriculum
well that's an interesting thing it's uh
you might be able to do double duty like
your current calls maybe you can record
them and that becomes content for the
channel or it's something new that
you're bringing in but it becomes part
of the marketing in that you take all
the different things that you're doing
you're fortunate enough to now actually
have a you're not just starting up and
have no students and trying to figure
out how to get this thing off the ground
right you have people been through
various levels of your programs all the
way up to certifications like the
highest level of what you would sell
right
right yes absolutely so you can take
some how many people have gone through
the certification
well let's put things in context there's
different certifications so there's some
certification that hundreds of people
there's some certifications I have
thousands of people right now they also
vary depending on on price points right
so I mean and we got to say I got people
that are certified from World Bank Ernst
young Central uh Central Bank of Curacao
Fannie Mae so I have huge companies but
many of the people are just everyday
people that just really like they really
wanted to get into blockchain and they
want to get into blockchain space and
they want to learn how can I apply to
these jobs well you take these courses
and you can apply for these jobs which
is a great opportunity and how much
one-on-one are you doing with these
people it depends on the certification
level so uh what I have I have a
community for example there's a Facebook
group where they're able to interact
between them and then depending on the
certification there's a certain number
of one-on-ones that we do and of course
they have any questions that we do some
one-on-ones now mind you I'm not against
it the question is would that be a
scalable approach because right now
you're able to give me a little bit of
your time but your time is really really
valuable how much one-on-one can you
really give right it's scalable through
content right so here's the thing if
George George is really busy George
doesn't do one-on-ones you can even stop
doing one-on-one this is George's
trainers who are coming and doing all
certification but to get actually George
is launching a new show
where he will Coach
whatever you're struggling with you
cannot buy 45 minutes of George's time
or however long you want to be like this
show is going to be a part of the show
yeah that makes sense here it is so if
you've been through the certification
and you want 25 minutes with with George
to answer whatever questions you have to
help you take your your training you're
learning to the next level do you want
to come on and be with him and some
people will say no
cool and some people will like what I
get time with George this is insane of
course like just like we're doing right
now
some people say now and some people say
yes and again but people will go on
Jerry Springer they'll go on your show
right one thing while we're here I want
to ask you a different question this is
new for me this is I I don't do
Instagram because I haven't done
Instagram
um I've spent time on my YouTube my chat
my YouTube channel I'm not where you're
at but I'm a 26 000 subscribers so I
think of when I think of publishing
content I think I gotta create contest
so I can publish on YouTube now I've
I've created a new process to be able to
do shorts and I'm doing five shorts per
week something Monday Tuesday wait
Monday through Friday and then I publish
a brand new video full length on
Thursdays I have two YouTube channels I
have the George Levy brand and The
blockchain Institute brand so for
instance you had a hard time today
because you didn't know what I'm talking
to George and I was in your audience but
this IG is blockchain Institute it's not
really George Levy right so the question
is am I doing myself a disservice by
diluting my brand between both Brands
that's what I'm trying to think it's a
brand new thing it's also an effort and
time thing a personal brand is easier to
scale because people love a face
people's like people when you first
joined I didn't know who you were I
didn't you know but then like the energy
and the excitement and George cares so
much about blockchain like it's great
right so like people want to learn from
a passionate instructor and if even if
it's not that even if it's not you
teaching everything your team it's like
you're the guy at the top who then
recruits the instructors who are going
to teach it so and it's a lot nobody has
a ton of Association to a logo typically
it's like you you're the guy
um makes sense so it's easy to make it
under under your brain but in terms of
the content
just to finish the point on on the
certification people coming through who
you're going to do lives with it doesn't
have to be alive like this it could
still be on Zoom dude Zoom
so you've got a nice looking Studio the
other person coming on doesn't have
everybody is now Zoom capable sure we've
all been trying all the time I do zooms
all the time this is a new creature for
me but okay I could do Zoom sure do it
on zoom and here's what's gonna happen
they're gonna come on and you're gonna
say hey here's Susan she just completed
our XYZ certification now we're talking
about the certification without talking
about the certification right it's not
it's not a Salesman Susan is going to
say oh my God George your certification
was awesome I love that I learned so
much now she's talking about a
certification without talking about
certification and then you're going to
help her and the content is super easy
you don't need Susan to give you a five
page list of her background and
everything you're going to show up just
like this I don't know what we're
talking about right you're going to show
Absolutely you know what you're talking
about inside of blockchain and Susan's
going to ask you questions that you
already know how to answer because
you've answered them a thousand times
before and then that creates amazing
content for your channel but it also
helps me learn oh George does
certification oh Susan and love the
certification cool maybe I should get in
on that as well so we're working with
our current customers
and then taking them just a level deeper
but people who already love us and
they're going to say great things about
us because if you just made a video
saying here's my new certification why
you should sign up nobody's gonna watch
that video nobody's going to go and sign
up like that video is done arrival but
if you're making it valuable but you're
bringing people in who love you and
we'll talk about the certifications like
you know in module 4 when you said blank
how do I right so we get that sprinkle
you don't even have to prompt it you
don't have to say certification it
should just come up in the conversation
um and so if you had some who've done
hundreds and some that are thousands you
already have a big enough pool to pull
from
but you can then use that same strategy
for any of your products that you offer
the free downloads that you have any of
the guides any of the courses hey here's
here's Bill he just completed my course
on blockchain 101. Bill welcome aboard
man like oh my God blockchain 101 George
it was great thank you for making that
course it made it so easy for me
sure here's what I'm trying to do and
then you go and help Bill and then in
the link you can link up your blockchain
101 course right it's the easiest kind
of content to make
because you don't have the script you
don't have to plan you don't have to
prepare you just show up you just have
to have your assistant book George and
Bill and who and Susan and whoever to
kind of be on your show which I saw you
have a beautiful system you have a
beautiful beautiful process set up you
actually you know I've been following
you for many many years and I got to
tell you one of the things that I love
most about what you're doing is that in
the process of going through this with
you I'm actually learning a lot of what
you're doing which I have to say to
anybody that still is not part of this
movement you've got to get on this
program so generally and I can see how
these can be a valuable marketing
vehicle because you got people like me
who are passionate about your work
telling everybody in the audience how
amazing this is did it all right like at
the beginning she's part of my movement
makers program and when I grow up I want
to be like Heather
but you you don't have to do it on on IG
you know definitely you just do inside
Zoom but it becomes YouTube content and
then the best moments from that get
clipped for tick tock for YouTube shorts
for reels for everything else I would if
your goal is to convert people I would I
would highly recommend you move more
towards long-form content than shorts
sure shorts are are great for audience
growth but a lot of us people who watch
shorts don't then go watch long form
content and they don't go and buy your
stuff
interesting so the goal is I want people
to buy my stuff get in my certification
because somebody who's in a short
mindset they're like they're scrolling
it's got to be something else instantly
they're not in the mindset I'm gonna go
watch a 45 minute training session I'm
gonna go get certified on this it's just
a different psychology so it's greatest
filter content so if you're making one
video a week then to have six shorts
cool do it but I'd much rather you go to
three or four or five long form videos
and less shorts because it's going to
help you achieve your business
objectives a lot more
and that's very very valuable because
one of the things the shorts creeper is
brand new to me so like for example when
I think about Instagram I think of reels
quite frankly I don't know anything
about Instagram so there's this thing
called reels there's this new thing
called YouTube shorts there's this I
don't use tick tock right so like I've
always been on the YouTube space and
I've built towards building my channel
right and now I'm seeing all these
different channels and I'm saying okay
so I need to go short from so what
you're telling me is that yes you'll be
able I'll be able to I guess I would be
able to find new subscribers but those
subscribers will not necessarily be the
the Die Hard subscribers that go through
my long form content that's a very low
conversion over to your long form
content and an even real conversion onto
whatever you're selling whatever they're
buying no they just want little quick
tidbits of content yeah quick quick bite
so that's beautiful filler content so
what I would start is long form content
and if you really want to hack it and
just make it easy to be everywhere
then you take your log from content if
you're going to talk to somebody for 45
minutes or however long your show is
going to be you're going to have
multiple aha moments and you're going to
drop some bombs and some gems in there
that maybe you've never shared before
but it'll come out as you're talking to
people it's just going to happen
you take that 45 second clip and I I
would keep it the 45 seconds or less
45 seconds or less you cut it and this
could be someone in your team but you
cut it to be vertical because all the
all the short from
and then you put that to Instagram reels
YouTube shorts Tick Tock and Twitter
because it's under 45 seconds so I could
still use Twitter I never thought about
that Twitter is the 25 seconds is the
limit the other ones you can go longer
but 45 is the limit on Twitter and for
where you are Twitter is important
sure for nft Twitter is Twitter crypto
super important and so I would
definitely be making Twitter content uh
I mean it's good for everybody
when it's easy because if you're making
the same piece of content and you're
posting everywhere go for it but
especially for you I would prioritize
Twitter over Instagram
that's great it's going to create a lot
better because I do have a I do have a
Twitter following and I've been building
it throughout the years and that's great
I didn't even consider it because I
don't think of Twitter as a video
platform the fact it's a 45 second video
can fit on Twitter that makes sense
groovy that's perfect Evan thank you
very much for sharing that with me I
actually have a team right now that is
going through all my videos and clipping
it into little shorts little shorts
little shorts but I've told them to do
60 seconds maybe what I should do is
start thinking about doing some longer
form content and then saying cut out
those little clips from the longer form
content yeah and do it like that that
longer form content I can also do in a
in an individual session with a student
somebody that's been certified yeah
that's great yeah very valuable
and also Twitter uh again when you're
doing your log form videos you're gonna
have a bunch of one-liners that you say
too that you could pull out as quotes
like text quotes for your Twitter
account and Twitter is very forgiving
like you could post 20 times a day on
Twitter it doesn't matter so I'd be
taking clips and the one-liners and
posting that to Twitter but it all you
don't have to think about new stuff all
you have to do is do your long form
content and then the team Cuts up all
the pieces and takes everything out and
now you're on every single platform just
by doing your regular shows
that's fantastic so certification
students customers is a series and you
can even do them all on one day or or
you know an afternoon once a week or
whatever and your system just lines them
up for you
45 minute breaks you know or half an
hour at a time and you line up six
students to go back to back and you're
doing three hours of calls and then you
got content for the next couple months
um that's awesome
then whatever your regular training
videos are too uh plus if you if you're
able to talk about anything trending
anything in the news anything that you
have an opinion on even if you don't
have to have like a hard like you're
gonna piss people off intentionally but
in an educational way just take that
vibe that you said there's so much good
that's happening that people don't know
about right what are those things and
then you start to be the guy who shares
it that brings you that which other
people don't have access to because I'm
on the inside I deal with a lot of these
yeah so that makes sense whatever those
things are in your mind if that could be
a weekly show to say here's what this
here's what's happening here this
company this new coin or whatever you're
going to talk about
um be the guy who's spreading those sins
instead of having to spread the
negativity
that's excellent thank you very very
much Evan I don't know what your
timeline is for these but uh uh it's
been flying for me and I'm really really
valued you know I've got a lot of value
this one final question on these are
these at all recorded by any chance is
any of this recorded this is recorded
like Instagram lives go to become
recorded so here's my process right so
your Movie Makers if people bought for a
year they get a chance to do the
one-on-one with me right so it's a
different like you can even this wasn't
sold but you could sell it right even as
part of your certification they could
buy one-on-one time with George that
also becomes a video to go on your
YouTube channel maybe that's a thousand
dollar plus thing to get the one-on-one
time with you and the content but for me
it's just built in it's free to do an
Instagram live this this will be saved
on my Instagram afterwards so after when
this is done it'll be there you can
watch it back you know that's exactly
what I think that's because I'm gonna
take notes from all this but right now
I'm holding my phone in my hand and I
didn't even put on my headset I'm like
yeah it's all good anyway and then we
take the best ones and and we'll convert
it to a YouTube video
excellent so that's fantastic moving
from Instagram to YouTube you just have
to we're on top of each other here we
just gotta rotate it to be side by side
but we're like that's cool but I
wouldn't even free like I wouldn't
recommend it for you just do Zoom and
then post a little bit of editing go
right to YouTube and then cut the clips
to build on every platform YouTube and
Twitter should be your top I mean
Discord if you have your own Community
like that's where that's where your
people are hanging out you can post
Clips post your 45 second Clips there's
a new George Section George's thoughts
there's a channel in your Discord
George's thoughts George's right Georges
what's a g Georges
George's what do you eat George's snacks
George I don't know something with the G
no no I I have a section where I always
say hi it's George live with another
valuable cryptocurrency clip and that's
a little that's typically my little
cryptocurrency clip and uh and I say you
know like I'll tell you something about
like what's the difference between a
coin and a token I keep it under under
60 seconds and that's a cryptocurrency
clip join me later for more
cryptocurrency Clips something like
that's what I always say it's like a
little clip something like that I would
do anyway we do all of that and just cut
out the intro extra
oh cool
yeah just when you do it don't don't
even I don't have to say hi shortly with
another valuable cryptocurrency clip
screw that yeah tell me the tip good
yeah
that's awesome and and you don't even
need to Now record these because you can
pull the clips from your videos
like in this there's been a bunch of aha
moments that my team could pull out and
turn those into me sharing so I don't
even know what I said today I don't know
I said stuff cool those could all be
clipped into different pieces of content
that I can put on different channels if
you have your Discord then again
whatever you're posting to Twitter the
45 second video that you're posting
everywhere could also be a daily clip to
your Discord let's pull some of the
stuff that you've already talked about
yeah and the key thing like for example
right now this this Instagram channel is
empty I don't have anything in there I
think I have one video that I recorded I
put in there and the question is I have
a whole stack of like 60 second or less
videos from before which I believe is
under the reels limit right 60 seconds
yeah
and the question is if I have those uh
does the platform because I haven't even
tried this afterwards if I have it in my
phone I can upload a video into it I
don't have to record something to put
into Instagram live yeah you can
definitely upload
really that's awesome or give it to you
like just give access to your team to
upload the content and then they can put
it up for you
cool and that's the final one I'm not
going to waste your time on that one but
the thing is like I'm thinking I have to
do everything through this device in my
hand right like not on my computer or
anything like that which would be
different I'm just so used to using a
computer that's it okay yeah every
platform pretty even YouTube is pretty
easy to upload from your phone or from
your team's phone
don't get groovy yeah awesome all right
thank you let's go George thanks for the
love thank you very much you did it
absolutely thank you so very much okay
have a beautiful one thank you
Jeffrey's in the house
hey Evan great to meet you really happy
to be here thanks for the opportunity
yeah cool man so Jeffrey's a new member
of movement makers and as part of that
we're doing this session together so you
got the pin podcast
I love it there you go I got very
inspired right at the beginning of covid
last year and read the whole thing so
um yeah thanks for everything you do for
so many people
cool man I love it so you got the pin
podcast we got some time together how
can I help how can I serve what do you
got right well I wanted to explain to
you what I'm trying to do and that I
have a few questions and wanted to hear
your suggestions but um I think you've
heard about what it's all about so
really the the idea is uh to lend
another hand up to all of the people and
all of the organizations that are trying
to end mental health stigma and so for
myself
um I had an experience I had a lived
experience
um almost 10 years ago I was I was an
entrepreneur
um and I have you know a family of six I
all sorts of things we're not working
out some contracts were ending in any
event at the end of this I I had a
mental breakdown and um so I was
hospitalized for five weeks and you know
it's a bit ironic to me because if
somebody had asked me or friends who
haven't seen me in years that asked me
if I was a likely candidate for that
they would have said no way and even
myself I thought there's no way that
could happen to me and I remember once
actually walking along the street with
other other patients of the ward going
to another hospital and and it's in my
hometown and I've done a lot of
volunteer work so I I was thinking in my
mind anybody who sees me thinks oh
Jeff's a nice guy he must be
volunteering again it's like no no I'm
not volunteering I'm I'm I'm a patient
and I'm needing some help so I was
thinking hard for years what can I do
I've come to the conclusion of making
this podcast
and and the whole the whole thing is to
try to reframe the thinking of weakness
when people are really getting crushed
and so it's using a weightlifting if you
go and do a bench press even with the
lightest amount and you don't stop where
you normally do which would be doing the
largest you know you stop with the last
rep and you you hand it to someone you
stop when it's on your chest and you
can't move and and that's a way to prove
universally it doesn't matter how strong
you are even the strongest man or woman
in the world would be pen and and I
think we can all get surprisingly pinned
when life throws way too much at you and
then you have to hide in the dark
because you're embarrassed that you have
a resulting Mental Health Challenge or
if you get sideswiped with
um you know with with a with
schizophrenia or bipolarity or other
things anyway so so that's what I'm
trying to create I'm doing some posts I
want to interview people who have really
overcome something and have an important
story to tell as a hand up for others so
that's the background and it's great to
meet you because I'm just starting out
but there's lots of questions I haven't
I'm sure you could give me incredible
advice
um so thank you for the opportunity
yeah I mean I love it I love one your
willingness to share there's so many
people who you know are too afraid and
if they were in the hospital they'd be
trying to hide and like oh my gosh don't
you know you know I yeah I'm a volunteer
here like you lie instead of showing
that no like I'm I struggle with this
too
um especially when we have you know some
kind of persona or we're kind of known
um so you know kudos to you are having
the courage to do that and now step up
and and create content so it's beyond
just that people need local community
but people you know around America and
the world who start to to see this
because I think the more people share
their story the more people can connect
to it the less they feel alone the less
they slide down
um and at some point everybody feels
pinned by something whether whether it
leads to a five-week stint in a mental
hospital or not right I mean that we
everybody feels pinned at some point I
think it's I think it's badly needed so
absolutely yeah I'm pumped so what do
you got what are your questions let's
try to help well for for example I mean
I've started off with an Instagram page
pin dot podcast so welcome anybody who'd
like to follow that I started off with
12 posts each with a picture and with a
story behind it that is always trying to
lead to you know basically a real
observation but a positive uplifting
message so what I wanted to ask you to
start is you know I I haven't created
any schedule for that I'm basically as I
get inspired I put something on but I
don't know if over the long run it's
better to say I have a discipline saying
you're gonna do one a day or two a day
or x a week versus if I'm inspired I put
something on and if I'm not there may be
a gap for a certain period of time yeah
it's definitely good to have a Content
schedule
if you wait there's nothing wrong with
being inspired it's great like yes you
get inspired create but if you wait
until you're inspired then you might
have maybe have a rough couple weeks you
know you're dealing with your kids and
whatever else like oh I haven't posted
this is where a lot of people fall under
right you know this I am going crazy
right now on my Discord getting you you
got to get in because you're mover
makers so I'm I'm building it up I'm
going crazy on it but this was in my
calendar and so I'm breaking from that
to come and do this right yesterday was
my YouTube day and so I put it in my
calendar and my team is not talking to
me and I'm not doing any other projects
I'm just filming videos if I didn't have
that block in my calendar
I wouldn't make the videos because
there's always something that has to get
done now it's not that I wouldn't make
the occasional video when I'm inspired
but you have to put it in your calendar
um those ones you can block right so
you could block time like you put a in
in one hour you could probably get a lot
of content done if you're just talking
about pictures with with some quotes
um and what I would try to do is use if
you feel inspired to make a video and go
great if if it's sometimes I'll get
inspiration for ideas and just email
myself and then I'll have a list of
things so that when it comes to content
day I'm not oh what do I
what am I going to make today and now I
have a folder that I can go through and
then create the content around
and and that that could be you can get
inspiration from anywhere you know maybe
you're walking down the street and you
see an act of kindness or that tree
reminds you of when you were depressed
and you you know cried under a tree like
there's so many sources of inspiration
um but yeah if you wait it's just it's
just not gonna happen like if you didn't
have this this was scheduled by my
assistant right in your calendar so
we're here yeah for you too like if this
wasn't in your calendar you'd probably
be doing something else that is not
creating content so finding you know at
the beginning if you're just posting
pictures with quotes those are a lot
easier to create than than video I would
I would find an hour to two a week put
it in your calendar whenever you feel
most inspired usually and put it in and
I've been learning lessons through just
try it's not trial and error just trial
really because so I was really happy and
it kind of made a light bulb go off for
me and I wonder what your comments are
but I you know I thought one of the
images I'd love to put on is of somebody
ice climbing because that's very tough
very specialized slippery slope and it's
it's these are always analogies or
metaphors to the slippery slope of when
you're in danger because you know you
have a mental health challenge I I found
a woman on Instagram who also I saw this
she does air what is it called air
um aerial kind of aerial gymnastics and
she she had an incredible quote she was
hanging by like this thread over a
forest maybe a thousand feet up but she
was admitting that she's terrified of
needles so to get coveted shots she was
terrified of needles so she was
reminding her her audience hey everybody
is afraid of something you're stronger
than you think and I thought this is
incredible what what a great and what a
great story for people because she must
be one of the most courageous people in
the world my whole my whole point and my
question to you though Evan is
um you know so I reached out to her and
I explained to her what I what I'm doing
and I said I would love to if you don't
mind share that picture with the quote
and this is what I'm doing and she said
absolutely fine just just um
just uh make sure you you know credit
the photographer so so would you
encourage
um you know movement makers
entrepreneurs obviously to to see
content at times like this if it fits in
with and if it makes sense to the person
you know that you may be asking to to to
to bring in you know shared content from
from from others that really make your
message Stronger Yeah I think so the
collaborations are great and and I would
go a step further and invite her to be
on your podcast you know like you mean
she maybe she didn't post her her story
of how she got pinned you know how she
may have felt penned in her life but she
has a story right you know for sure
everybody's got their own story of of
feeling pinned and it's a great opening
for the podcast because most people when
they're doing interviews and if you go
back and movement makers we had a
section of how to be a great interviewer
not just interviewee and how I love
opening up an interview is saying
something personal about them because
most people when they're doing
interviews they read their bio and it's
just super boring like you got to sit
through okay let me tell you about Jeff
Jeff has a you know and you're it's
boring Jeff has tuned out because he
doesn't want to hear his own bio again
and you have the same intro on your
podcast as everybody else has so the
best way to introduce them is to say
what you like about them because now you
have unique content but it also makes
them feel special because it shows that
you care and there's a reason why
they're here so this woman probably has
tons of accolades and success and maybe
she said some World Records or you know
whatever she's got tons of athletes to
her name but if you said hey here is
Maria and why I love Maria is because of
this story and then you share about
needles and pine trees and hanging a
thousand feet over and all that stuff
and right you can totally skip her
entire bio
and she's gonna feel way better like
that might be the best introduction
she's ever had on a show because it's
from the heart because it's a genuine
like you actually
love this thing about this person right
so yeah I love it like whether it's as
simple as just a picture that you love
when you're crediting them great
um but I would try to see if you can go
a step further and ask them to be on
your show and then leave with that intro
and then and then at some point you dive
into hey how have you felt pinned in
your life and again everybody's got some
kind of story to share right fantastic I
wanted to ask you about the different
platforms because my intention is to to
start uh the podcast you know sooner
than later uh again I'm just I'm just PR
I've got a list of people who have
started to agree to be interviewed and
and I know that you've encouraged us uh
to uh to to to go on to YouTube for
example and also to post maybe 100
videos Try It Out Etc so so I just
wanted your general comments as somebody
who's starting out again my intention
was to start with Instagram uh to do a
podcast and then I've spoken to a couple
of friends who who are doing podcasts so
getting the technical side but maybe if
I know you talk about this a lot but
just for somebody at an early stage like
me you know the comments on the use of
the different different Medias
yeah so tomorrow's session in movement
maker is going to be great because I
think that the topic is how would I get
started on YouTube well like if I was
starting right now so it's geared
towards getting started but for podcasts
YouTube for sure
so you're thinking how do I record video
and the easiest way to do it is actually
on an Instagram live like this could be
this could be saved as a video and and
might make it to you know one of my
YouTube channels then you could rip the
audio and turn that into all of the
audio platforms for your podcast
and then the third would be Instagram
either the whole thing because you're
doing it live and now you have it saved
right and also Instagram is the easiest
way for you to reach people
so YouTube is the best but it's going to
be a long-term play it'll take a while
to build up momentum and steam and
people to get to know you and algorithm
pick up and all that YouTube is but it's
the best long-term play for you to build
this brand because what you're talking
about
you know unfortunately in two years and
five years and seven years is still
going to be a problem
you know like it's it's we're trying to
make our dent in the universe but
unfortunately you're talking about
mental health it's still going to be a
problem in two years five years of
course so that's yeah yeah content that
content you put up on YouTube will still
be valuable for people right but it's
just a longer term play so
um YouTube all the audio platforms and
then Instagram would be where I'd post
uh either the whole thing in Instagram
in igtv like this
uh or if you have any kind of editing
capabilities you could uh clip some of
the moments or even just take some of
the high if you like quotes take some of
the Highlight quotes like if you have
her on your show
and you're going to talk for half an
hour an hour whatever you're going to do
there's going to be five to ten quotes
that she says that you really love and
resonate right so you take you take
those quotes and you turn them into
pictures for your account as well
fantastic and then Instagram becomes the
easy place for you to DM people and
reach out to say hey I'd love to have
you as a guest on my show as well
fantastic another question is is is
based on that really when you're talking
about half an hour an hour and I'll give
you a specific example but you know the
type of people I I I'm going to be
talking to on the podcast I do have a
friend who was a star athlete in
University excellent athlete as a when
he became a professional successful
businessman father of three kids but
several years ago he took his sales team
the leading sales team to Hawaii took
surfing lessons and ended up breaking
his neck himself in an accident and has
been a quadriplegic ever since so he has
certainly been massively pinned both
physically and mentally he's gone
through a lot of things but he's
somebody who wants to share his story
and none of this is trying to sugar coat
anything right and as I've said in my
thing too I'm not I have no medical
expertise I'm looking to help people
share stories on my own as a as to try
to make sure we all know we're human and
that we can we can seek that head hand
up when we feel there's nowhere to turn
and we've got reasons to to not want to
you know feel less than who we are I
think we're we're not as good as others
so Mike my question to you is I've
spoken to him already I don't know you
know if this should be a half an hour
discussion or an hour discussion if you
target it in advance or you just let it
go with a whole bunch of questions and
if it turns out that he's only
comfortable or we've talked for half an
hour and that's it you you stop there or
you edit it or should should we always
Target the same amount of time or even
extra time if you're gonna edit as well
yeah that's a great question so
already from the vibe that I'm getting
from you
I think you'll what you do is create a
safe space for people to actually share
their story
and it's it's not so much about you
talking talking but you're gonna ask
questions and then just give them a
space yes you'll be a great listener and
you'll give them a space to share their
story and you might be the only person
who's ever asked them in a way where
they can share their story make them
feel comfortable enough to do it right
so I think I think that becomes the
Cornerstone to say hey I'm just like you
maybe not like obviously you're not a
quadriplegic but I'm I'm like you and
that I struggled with this and here's
the purpose like you lead with the
mission
um and then
already just in how you show up and your
tone and your care and and the
thoughtfulness behind your questions and
just how you're paying attention when
they're talking uh because like when you
see it as I'm talking
it would not surprise me that you would
get information and stories out of them
that they've never shared anywhere else
so
uh you would like to have a lot of time
for them to get into it because it's
like oh okay Sally sorry we gotta go now
off of somebody like if they're in the
middle of this really emotional sword
that have never told anywhere else
um you want to make sure that there's
time for that so
there's no upper limit
uh I encourage people to go long if you
if you have the time and they have the
time
longer is always better especially for
YouTube
so one of the main reasons why people
like Joe Rogan took off is
they're like three hour podcasts
you know you're sitting down and you're
talking for three hours now that's a lot
of commitment and that's a lot of work
right uh so you have to have buffer time
on your calendar and it's also always
smart to ask them if they have a heart
out yeah right do you have to be
somewhere do you have to go pick up your
kids you have another because you don't
want to be
disrespectful of their time and I know
you wouldn't so it's just asking if they
have a heart out you can say sometimes
conversations go we can budget an hour
but sometimes they go less sometimes
they go more is there a heart out I
should be
I should know about you know and then go
in as long as you can
um there's always more levels that you
can go and I think you'll know when to
end it you know like there's just a vibe
to a conversation where it feels like
okay that's a that's a great spot to end
on thank you so much for popping in
um
yeah so I wouldn't I wouldn't fix myself
in
because you want them to have the
permission to share their story and
sometimes it takes a long time to get
out
yeah I was gonna ask I was gonna ask too
because of my life experiences and and
the reason I'm doing this and then
people I've met along the way you know I
would like to intersperse this at
different times with different stories
so it's a question of how to do that
because the goal of each podcast is to
is to allow somebody to to come forward
and share their story again this isn't
sugar coating anything a lot of these
are very very difficult stories but they
are ending with hope in some ways and
and hopefully we can also lend a hand up
to the the person sharing too if they
are still pinned or need some help but
my question to you and I'll give you a
very quick story which is an example but
you know when I was uh a teenager I
worked a lot with with disabled kids
because my mom was working at a school
for them and I I worked with a girl who
had a bliss board and I'd worked with
several kids who only communicated by uh
pointing at symbols and this is an
example of a short story so I would I
would I didn't know her I would go say
hello to her every morning at a camp she
would never respond and I thought I was
bugging her so after about three or four
days I asked another counselor I said
should I leave her alone I must be
bugging her she's not responding and
they said you don't know how she
communicates and I and I felt indignant
you know because I've worked with a lot
of kids with bliss boards and I this
isn't my first kid that I worked with
and and I said of course I do and they
said no you don't they said look at her
eyes if she looks up she's saying yes
and if she looks down she's saying no
and so I didn't know that so when I went
to see her I started pointing at symbols
she's looking up I'm offering
conversation she's looking down
I tell her uh you must have thought I
was pretty stupid eh because I couldn't
communicate with you and she looks up
right so we're having this great
Community great communication but and
she is a perfect example of somebody
I've met who is completely pinned and
yet if somebody can't give her a hand up
and get into her world she's got a very
challenging life regardless but the
Dignity of her human spirit is amazing
so my whole question to you is you know
when I when I do a podcast I've got to
figure out over time how I can bring in
appropriate stories of others and
experiences that are relevant and
intersperse them and maybe it's just
part of the conversation but I guess and
maybe I'll learn that
yeah well I mean you will and you'll
find your style as the more you do you
can't have the perfect plan going in
like no matter how much you plan you
know to be a parent
sure
right it's always different right you're
you're you're birthing a new child here
so no matter how much you plan and get
prepared you know it's it's going to be
its own experience which is fine and
beautiful
um a couple things come to mind first is
you mentioned at the beginning in the
setup maybe even help the guests become
a little more unpinned as well if they
have something they're going through I
would default to to thinking and even
making an intention that in by them
sharing their story
aimed by them feeling like they're
contributing something that their story
might mean something to somebody that is
unpinning themselves right like they may
not need any other follow-up or anything
else just the fact that they're having
this conversation is the process of on
pinning because I think a lot of the
process of unpinning is just feeling
like you're not doing this alone
just straighten it out like that keeping
it stuck here and like pressure and all
this and like hey get it out you've
already unpinned them just by giving
them the space right right
um so that's one second for the content
you have two options it's either if
you're gonna start talking for for you
know a third to a half of the episode
then you could either you you need to
position it more as a conversation
instead of an interview
because if people are expecting the
interview and then you're interjected
and telling your stories and all that
then it's like why am I being
interviewed or so that makes a little
awkward if it saves a conversation with
Jeff then that's a different thing that
they're signing up for
um option two could be you have solo
episodes so you have your interview show
and then you have your Jeff show
and the Jeff shows you're telling you're
telling a story with a message and that
may not be an hour three hours of you
sitting in front of a microphone you
know there could be shorter episodes
right but the ones that come to mind and
you could even in in thinking about the
guests you've had all the stores that
you wanted to share even take a little
quick note and instead of sharing them
live because your goals to get more
information out of your guest then it's
a solo episode with Jeff talking about
the other stories that you want to share
there's no right or wrong it's really
more the vibe you want to create when
you're talking you're not learning so as
a goal to learn as much from the person
you've got while you've got their time
or as a goal to have more of a
conversation
it's really more what you're curious
about but but setting that up in advance
because again if you say hey I'd love to
interview you and then you're talking
for half the time that could rub some
people the wrong way not knowing to sign
up for a conversation absolutely no
thanks for telling me that because that
would have been unintentional but uh I
can imagine yeah probably some people
the wrong way like you said
and then it's also making it timely
right like the story that you tell needs
to be relevant to what you guys are
talking about yeah you know so that
they're learning in it too but people
people would sign up for both you just
have to again and make that intention
clear from the beginning right all right
yeah there's there's other odds and ends
that come to mind but I I think I guess
I may be out of time but I I really
appreciate it Evan I'm excited and you
know it's it is uh you know your book
built to serve was really resonated with
me because this this is this is what I I
want to do I've wanted to do it for a
long time but I I wrote an article but I
I figured um everybody has a story like
you say it just depends on how far you
you've gone you know and unfortunately
like I wrote a little a little um post
on my 105 year old relative who um his
way to keep going was yeah his his way
to keep going was every morning he would
walk to the mirror and the old folks
home and say oh good Alf you're still
here and he would literally do that he
had a sense of humor and then uh he
would bet people a dollar that he would
celebrate more birthdays than them in
the future and then he would explain to
them later if they took the bet that he
celebrates his birthday every day
because he's not sure how many years
he's gonna be around and his every day
is an anniversary of his birth so please
pay up now you know and so um all I'm
saying is that you know he he is a he's
a great example it taught everybody
around him that even at 105 like he
wasn't he was a bit pinned by time but
he wasn't pinned in terms of his human
spirit and so so there's an endless
number of people who who can share
stories and because I think there's way
too many people who are crushed right
now and having been crushed myself or
pinned is the way I'm trying to describe
it this is just a hand up that's what
it's for
especially if you can bring in all those
different stories like 105 year old guy
in an old age home other person who's uh
you know afraid of needles but can
dangle from you know all these meters up
in the air other persons are
quadriplegic like the more you can show
the different versions of pinned the
more people will resonate with it and to
say oh my gosh that person I didn't get
it before when you had the quadriplegic
on I didn't get it didn't fit me because
I'm not struggling with that same thing
but I am afraid of getting old or
whatever right it's like the more
stories you have on the more people will
find something specific to them that
they say wow this episode changed my
life right which is the whole point of
what you're trying to do right fantastic
amazing awesome Jeff well it's a great
start great we'll see you tomorrow
thanks very much to show up on the road
thanks all the best thank you all right
much love Jeff cheers take care bye to
see me coach another entrepreneur one on
one check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there how do I
build a network Across America of not
just the survivors but the helpers
because that leads to so many things for
the rest of your life for the rest of
the movement that you're you're trying
to build and create this is how you give
Hope by sharing your story because if
you're silent it perpetuates Asylum